foreign
doesn't have to be the term gender but
we need to have the idea of the hardware
of Sex and the software of sex being
different even in humans and the reason
that we do is because cultures are so
different this is this is not an
arbitrary fact
in humans
the a huge fraction more than in any
other creature a huge fraction of the
evolutionary information has been
offloaded by The genome into the
software layer
that creates some vulnerabilities and it
creates a massive opportunity for Rapid
Evolution that can therefore be highly
precise to particular environments or
particular circumstances this is the
magic of humans
and that magic of humans means that
sex roles do change they are not
completely flexible to another excellent
lesson that you were fond of was the
going into the anthropological
literature and looking at the patterns
that are violated where you know sex is
arbitrarily do certain jobs but a lot of
jobs are not arbitrarily distributed a
lot of jobs are not arbitrarily
distributed we're talking about things
like everything from like hunting marine
mammals
to Gathering a vegetable foods to basket
weaving to you know carting of of wool
and making of rope and the interesting
the interesting finding there is that
yes there are many jobs especially
because you've excluded there the
anatomically and physically mandated
things of gestation and lactation there
are a number of jobs like hunting of
brain mammals that in a culture where
it's done it's done by men yep but there
are also a number of jobs and we talk
about this in the sex engender chapter
of hunter-gatherer's guide that are
highly gendered but which gender does it
very strongly by culture which tells you
that it doesn't actually matter this
doesn't a manly work this isn't womanly
work it's just valuable for there to be
division of labor and that you know
that's that's a huge thing that the
whole gender ideology is missing it's
like you know what division of labor has
has been
um done terribly many many times but
there is value in division of labor and
he doesn't need to be done by sex but
that's an obvious way to split us
because we're about half and half and
all humans in throughout history who
have left descendants have been male or
female which raises some really
interesting questions and this is
another in addition to
a bunch of The evolutionary the Adaptive
uh
feature set of human beings being
offloaded to software which creates this
flexibility
it also creates it creates a potential
to to have an Adaptive culture set that
fits a particular environment but also
it allows a particular culture to change
over time and so we are in a position uh
it was for all cultures that war was the
province of men right
it is not inherently true that that
should remain the case if you are going
to be a fighter pilot
there might be certain things in which
the strength advantages a man has are
necessary but it is much less obvious
that a woman cannot be a fighter pilot
in combat
they're excellent
highly capable female pilots who are
going to be just as good or better in
combat now
doesn't mean that it makes sense to be
in combat people will raise the question
about what happens if a woman gets shot
down she has vulnerabilities that a man
does not have Behind Enemy Lines is that
enough that we should
forbid this is there a value to a
division of labor that isn't about such
concrete issues you know you point out
that in places where what sex does a job
reverses when you move from one culture
to another it's still done by one sex
there are presumably adaptive reasons
for that right single single sex culture
um is different
from from cultural interactions with two
Sexes right and actresses so I think
this is my personal belief I think that
the
um fact that women have so thoroughly
and effectively broken into the highest
levels of science is a great Triumph of
liberalism however there is a question
in it
men and women interact differently and
there's a question about
when women were excluded from that
environment unfair as that was to women
the culture of men where men by their
very nature push each other around is a
scientific modality or is at least one
of the components of a vibrant
scientific modality that the desire to
find what's wrong with what the other
person is saying is a core of how that
job is done well and the idea one will
find much more frequently that women
find an obligation to be supportive and
obligation to be supportive in a
scientific environment may be exactly
counterproductive and so no I actually I
wrote about this in my um
uh the piece that was published it was
invited for I think it's the archives of
sexual behavior on the different kinds
of competition that men and women engage
in and the different modes I was taught
I decided to talk not just about not
about science so much but about business
uh and and finance and said you know
look it may be uh that a a female
approach can be effective here but if a
female approach is more likely to be
cryptic and
um not to direct and as part of being
cryptic not public
uh it's going to take at best longer to
get things done and uh it's also likely
to lead to more conclu more confusion
and uh and make those people who are
looking for direct instruction direct
like did I do it right or did I not or
do you think that that was well done or
did you not leave them
um bewildered and not sure how to go
about things and you know there are
places where spending time Meandering
and thinking through all the
possibilities and not getting to the
point where we make a decision and get
something done is useful but we have to
recognize that these are different
styles which are broadly speaking
stereotypically sexed and uh and that in
a world where what you need to do is
make a decision and do it and then not
look back that is much more of a male
kind of of approach and something like
war or or any kind of combative
interaction as some business
interactions will be is much more suited
to a male typical style of Engagement
yes and in the case of the lab situation
there isn't I I I I'm sure you'll agree
uh and I speak professionally here the
correct thing to do
that recovers the maximal gains
available is not to exclude women from
that environment but to expect the male
mode to be learned in the same way that
we expect that everybody in a scientific
environment should understand the
scientific method and therefore be able
to figure out when they are in violation
of it right when they're
projecting a hypothesis back on a data
set that they didn't have before they
collected that data we expect people not
to do that and so anyway the point is I
would want to know exactly what is meant
by the mail mode I'm less compelled that
um in science precisely this is um that
male versus female
modes which we would have to Define very
precisely are inherently better I think
that um
not saying not being direct about a
critique of an idea is a problem and so
if that is what you are if that is what
you're putting under
um female mode here which certainly
could belong there I would say yes
that's not that's not appropriate that
actually when when you think you have
something when you when you have
something to say or a critique of
something that has been said uh you know
be be respectful I was about to say be
kind but that word has been weaponized
right like be respectful but also be as
direct as you can be and that is it is
harder for women to do it it is like
it's not just about conditioning yeah
but this is what I'm saying is the
Instinct okay but yeah but what what
there
but
this is a reflection of a male mode that
functioned in a laboratory context that
is inherent to the scientific exercise
the instinct to falsify
for me to find flaws in what the person
who is speaking is saying and to point
them out publicly right that mode is
um
it is
fundamentally
scientific and it is natively
man and just as you would not I don't I
so I I object to that final piece of
this but I think we're well in the weeds
I don't think I don't think we're in the
weeds
a soldier
who is female in an environment where
the battle is technological and
therefore female is not a disadvantage
is expected to take on a combative
a Killer Instinct
rather than a peacemaking modality
peacemaking modality is
counterproductive on the battlefield
sure so my point is this is it doesn't
matter it doesn't combat no it's not
combat but it is
um
antagonistic
I don't think so and I I do think this
is just
um this is ultimately a semantic
discrepancy in which
um you know I would I would ask that you
go back and look carefully at what I
have described as the very as as as male
typical and female typical uh kinds of
competition and without having those
definitions on the table in front of us
we're just going to be going back no no
I remember I remember what you wrote and
um the
undermining
is not
scientifically helpful it does not do
the job of being antagonistic it's not
that there's not an antagonistic mode in
the female typical but the you describe
it as cryptic and my point is that
within a lab group let's say right so
undermining is like combative right like
that's that's the that's the toxic
version of the two right so overt versus
covert right
um public versus versus cryptic uh if if
we are keeping the models
um male the male model of competition is
what I'm talking about
um and you're sort of extending it into
all interactions
um more more public more direct more
overt uh and female models being more
cryptic more covert
when in front of someone I think it in
order to determine whether or not what
they've got is actually As Good As It
Seems a more direct a more public
response is warranted however
there is a lot that is done uh through
thinking and through giving written
response for instance and so just as a
female typical model is more likely to
be comfortable with the written word uh
that having you know what what I used to
do for my students and what I used to do
in in grad school as well was go back
and forth a lot with in writing which I
became very skilled at I was very direct
but there is a time delay and it doesn't
require a face-to-face I think you're
wrong and here's why and I would do that
but I didn't always have it I didn't
know it necessarily and that doesn't
mean that I was hiding behind something
female or that that that femaleness was
was less good there is a different mode
that I think is potentially just as uh
just as appropriate and just as
effective but can manifest in a
different way
I agree and in the mentoring context
sure but I want to point out how this
has played out in recent history and I
think I think this will make it clear
the problem with the written critique
mode where critiques are leveled but
it's done in you know it's not done uh
overtly in the open it is over but there
is a time delay well
let's look at what happened with uh
with covet Origins yep
a debate was had
we didn't know a debate was at debate
was had over email written critique
people did hold each other to account
uh Power one out
Howard decided what the scenario was
going to be and the Very people who knew
exactly the things that made the
position unlikely fell into line before
it emerged into public and it was
presented as a consensus okay so you you
are responding to a grabbing and a
weaponization of what is a mode that can
be very effective and many men are
excellent at it but women may be
slightly more likely to be excellent at
it because of you know on average female
greater female capacity uh with words
compared to on average greater male
capacity with uh with numbers okay just
like lay that out there gets weaponized
as a way to obscure to hide to lie to uh
to pretend that things that we had the
discussion and we didn't have the
discussion that's that's entirely clear
and so you are arguing for an ability to
at the point that it seems like
something is being done out of view and
we are being told that is done being
done in View and ability to like pull a
rip cord and say now is the time now is
the time that we need to go back into an
historical mode that is not time delayed
that is you know real time very direct
here we go let's talk and you're going
to respond to to my critiques as we sit
here together and I think I think you're
absolutely right I don't know I don't
know how to get something like that to
implement and obviously you've had you
know you've had any number of people say
oh you know Brett's wrong and you say
okay let's talk oh God no I can't I I've
got to go cut my hair or something you
know well and you know and I'm much less
likely to say okay let's go
but I'm certain that the response would
be the same right but uh yes look
imagine that all of these things had
been done just simply in the open and it
is the difference between I'm just like
I'm just objecting to the in the open
part I know in this case there was a
bunch of stuff that was hidden but then
it pretended that it was in the open
well let's put it this so there is a way
to do critique with a time delay that is
still actually transparent I'm not
saying that that has been the case in
science for maybe ever okay okay I want
to make two points yeah we are in a
perilous situation yeah in a perilous
situation
meeting for coffee isn't meeting for
coffee
I know we're talking about yet you will
in a second there are people that you
might only be willing to meet in a
public place
because it is protective of something
that is an actual danger right
my point is scientifically speaking
that's where we are I don't want any
more [__] private discussions of
anything because we have seen that
private is the space in which somebody
decided to paint you and me as Kooks for
saying things that they privately
believed right right yeah I'm sorry wow
well that is so that is so far beyond
the pale that I don't want any more of
that I want public discussions because
those public discussions are the place
you can't pull that [__] right so yeah
that's that's a that's an already broken
down situation but
um then then then they'd have lied
visibly right I mean they would now be
they would be all along in the position
that they are now in that we have seen
their emails but what were the chances
we were going to see their freaking
emails yeah so my feeling is you know
what if you're gonna play this game by
your own rules if you're gonna if you're
gonna do this as Mean Girls then we're
gonna do this in public so that your
mean girl stuff comes back to haunt you
enough okay okay but I want to point out
that the idea of vigorous
um public often instantaneous critique
that I'm suggesting is more male in
nature it doesn't have to mean that we
are all out to embarrass each other
publicly and I want to point out that
shouldn't be the goal right it should
not be sometimes people need to be
embarrassed but in general in a proper
scientific culture it is exactly the
inverse and I want to point out that
inside of a laboratory
all right inside of a lap and Dick
Alexander's lab and Arnold cluge's lab
people held each other to account yes it
was not considered disrespectful it was
not understood to be mean and in fact
the real proper understanding of it is
it makes me stronger for you to throw
your best stuff at what I'm presenting
and see if what I'm presenting stands up
I will find out what's wrong with it if
you pointed out if I go out into the
world wearing a bunch of gold stars and
I don't know how to think that makes me
look stupid but it also makes the lab I
came out to look stupid
it's bad for everybody we all get
smarter together if we hold each other
to account properly and we do it
respectfully and it's not mean and you
know it's mean to let people think that
they're doing great when they're not yes
that's what is mean the height of
respect is to deliver proper critique
yes because you're honing somebody
else's weapon
foreign
[Music]